buonasera a tutti
la realizzazione del giardino della
biodiversità affonda le sue radici
nella storia di 470 anni circa
infatti per capire il giardino della
biodiversità
dobbiamo andare un po nel passato quindi
ancora una volta andiamo nel passato per
capire meglio il presente la storia
dell'orto botanico di padova l'orto più
universitario più antico del mondo
inizia nel 1545
da un'idea di francesco buona fede
francesco bonafede era il
docente che insegnano agli studenti di
medicina a riconoscere le piante e gli
si rese conto che studiare sui testi di
in genere testi greci
arabi latini con traduzione
approssimative e anche disegni molto
approssimativi non avrebbero certamente
aiutato gli studenti a riconoscere le
piante medicinali che dovevano essere
usate per la cura delle malattie
quindi chiese all'università di padova e
l'università chiesa la repubblica
serenissima di venezia di aiutarlo
nell'impresa e la repubblica serenissima
acquistò un territorio un piccolo lembo
di terra tra la basilica di santa
giustina e il sant'antonio quindi nacque
così il giardino dei semplici dove per
semplici si intende il
la pianta che dà il principio attivo
qui vedete nelle immagini due piantine
pressoché identiche una del 1591 quindi
quasi 50 anni dopo la fondazione del
l'orto botanico e l'altra della fine del
settecento ottocento scusate
a opera di saccardo che fu uno dei
prefetti dell'orto botanico
quindi questo orto botanico
comincia la sua storia come
orto medicinale e da quel momento
diventa l'orto botanico che ha
conservato la ubicazione
originaria e le principali
caratteristiche strutturali
architettoniche c'è pisa prima parlavamo
della toscana e che ci contende il
primato ma pisa ha spostato il suo orto
botanico originario due volte quindi
quello di padova è l'unico che mantiene
l'ubicazione originaria come potete
vedere nel qui vedete anche la struttura
architettonica che è stata sempre molto
apprezzata
dall'europa infatti molti orti botanici
si ispirarono a la pianta architettonica
e al modo di esporre le piante che
vedete qui quindi gli studenti di
medicina passeggiavano tra le aiuole
ogni parcella aveva una specie con il
proprio cartellino e quindi poteva
imparare dal vivo a riconoscere la
pianta
nato come orto dei semplici col tempo e
col cambiamento della
scienza che è diventata da scienza
applicata alla medicina a botanica
scienza pura
l'orto acquisisce delle nuove collezioni
e quindi oggi troviamo circa 6.000
specie quindi 6000 esemplari di specie
che provengono da tutto il mondo diviso
in collezioni tematiche
l'orto botanico di padova
anche un altro tipo di diversità di
biodiversità a una biblioteca antica
fornita di
20 mila libri adesso molto importanti
perché abbiamo presente prime stampe di
classici di teofrasto presenti o
dioscoride quindi illustri botanici
dell'antichità abbiamo l'opera di linneo
per esempio ma abbiamo anche un erbario
che vedete qui un erbario scusate che
racchiude 500 mila fogli di erbario
quindi raccolte provenienti da
tantissime parti d'italia ma anche
estere
l'orto botanico di padova ha subito
quindi questa trasformazione
e a un certo punto è stato riconosciuto
nel 1997 patrimonio
dell'unesco quindi fa parte della lista
del patrimonio mondiale unesco e come
vedete qui trovate la ragione per cui
l'orto botanico è stato iscritto nella
lista mondiale quindi rappresenta la
culla della scienza degli scambi
scientifici della comprensione delle
relazioni tra natura e cultura
e ha contribuito al progresso di
numerose discipline scientifiche
questo il primo evento che è capitato
nell'ultimo ventennio riconoscimento da
parte dell'unesco il secondo evento che
cambia il volto dell'orto botanico è
la possibilità di espandersi l'orto come
vedete nell'immagine si trova in un
contesto urbano ormai circondato da
edifici
nessuna possibilità di sviluppo
fortunatamente l'università di padova è
riuscito ad acquistare un terreno
confinante con l'orto botanico antico
e già nella carta di l'ingorgo del 1997
che detta le linee guida per gli orti
botanici storici europei
aveva sancito che l'unica possibilità di
sviluppo era costruire degli orti
satelliti quindi il progetto prende
corpo e se voi osservate a sinistra qui
vedete che il progetto
rispetta il
diciamo lo stesso impianto le stesse
proporzioni e la stessa diciamo
struttura che
collegamento visivo tra il santo e santa
giustina essi sito diciamo in questa
zona quindi collega visivamente le due
basiliche come faceva il vecchio orto
questo molto importante perché situa il
progetto in un contesto storico
monumentale qui vedete il progetto in
pianta e in particolare questa la parte
nuova
che ha confina con la parte col orto
antico e qui avete alcune diciamo
dati alcuni dati numerici che vi dicono
la lunghezza
quanto è il nuovo la nuova parte un
ettaro e mezzo e quante sono le specie
che abbiamo intenzione di piantumare
all'interno della serra
le serve sono costruite in modo da
diminuire l'impatto
sull'ambiente e quindi abbiamo un
sistema di pannelli fotovoltaici che ci
fornisce parzialmente l'energia di cui
abbiamo bisogno
l'energia mette in movimento
da alimenta tutte le pompe i sistemi
automatizzati che servono per
gestire le serre la vasca abbiamo una
vasca di 450 metri cubi che raccoglie
l'acqua piovana e che affianca l'acqua
che noi peschiamo da un pozzo artesiano
che a 285 metri di profondità l'acqua
viene tutta riciclata in modo che non ci
sia dispersione
il morto che adesso vediamo la parte
nuova nella prossima immagine che si
apre sul santa giustina e avete tutto il
complesso delle serre sulla sinistra
mentre in fondo alla parte bianca vedete
sono sarà la zona dove sorgeranno
laboratori di ricerca
dove sorgerà la banca del germoplasma
che potenzierà quella che già abbiamo
nell'orto antico perché un giardino
della biodiversità perché è importante
conservare la biodiversità il concetto
che sta sotto questa scena è quella di
ripercorrere in un viaggio ideale i
biomi della terra quindi le cascate che
vedete sempre con acqua riciclata
permettono di separare la serra
tropicale sul umida dalla serra
temperata e dalle serre
desertiche che poi finiscono poi con la
serra nella zona diciamo artica polare
quindi è un viaggio ideale attraverso
tutti i biomi della terra che vedete
rappresentati nel sinistra quindi qui
avete alcune immagini all'interno della
serra
oltre ad essere un viaggio attraverso i
biomi è anche un viaggio fitto
geografico perché abbiamo sapete
benissimo che ci sono zone per esempio
di clima mediterraneo non solo qui in
italia ma anche il sudafrica in
california quindi all'interno delle
serre il visitatore troverà
alberi e piante che
vengono dalle diverse parti della terra
e che condividono lo stesso tipo di
clima il visitatore quindi sarà
perfettamente immerso nella fascia
climatica e potrà ammirare e
confrontarsi con le specie che vengono
dalle varie parti del mondo
il visitatore potrà anche
diciamo
conoscere le piante da un altro punto di
vista uno dei percorsi previsti
all'interno delle serve oltre a quello
che abbiamo visto prima le piante e
l'ambiente è il percorso le piante e
l'uomo
l'uomo vive attraverso le piante noi
abbiamo visto da molti degli interventi
di oggi utilizziamo molto delle piante
mangiamo grazie alle piante ci vestiamo
grazie alle piante
ci diciamo anche vediamo godiamo delle
piante perché quando vediamo un fiore
molto bello ci fa star bene la cosa
quindi le piante l'uomo è il percorso
che permetterà al visitatore di
confrontarsi che cosa vuol dire
confrontarsi vuol dire per esempio
capire
che
la civiltà una civiltà in particolare
sarà
dipesa dal nel suo sviluppo dalle piante
che circondavano la zona dove lui viveva
e viceversa quell'uomo avrà influito
sulle piante che lo circondavano quindi
per farvi solo un esempio che conoscete
tutti
il caffè non ce lo conoscete questo la
pianta qui sotto e caffè è una pianta di
origine africana
e quindi non tutti compensiamo che sia
una pianta di origine brasiliana e
africana in realtà il primo a
descriverla fu prospero alpini il
prefetto dell'orto botanico nei suoi
viaggi in egitto
descrisse l'uso che le popolazioni
egiziane facevano dei chicchi tostati e
da quel momento dobbiamo ringraziare
appunto prospero alpini quando viviamo
una tazzina di caffè da lì i veneziani
non portarono lo spostarono in italia e
in altre zone dell'europa e poi la
diffusione del clima nel clima adatto
della zona brasiliana ha fatto sì che il
brasile diventasse il maggiore
produttore di caffè al mondo ma possiamo
fare tanti altri esempi la biodiversità
va mantenuta perché per esempio possiamo
trovare nuove fonti di alimentazione
noi adesso ci nutriamo
praticamente di una trentina di piante
esempio tra i quali cereali come abbiamo
già sentito le piante
cereali sono solito a fonti di
alimentazione
ci sono moltissime piante selvatiche che
vivono in zone climatiche diverse che
possono dare lo stesso alimentazione per
esempio sotto vedete il pieno podio fino
a che è una pianta che appartiene alla
famiglia degli spinaci produce dei
chicchi simili a quelli dei cereali che
sono utilizzati da moltissime
popolazioni indigene per l'alimentazione
ancora importante mantenere la
biodiversità
per esempio per
curarci quindi negli in alto lì a
sinistra vedete la cantò tech acuminata
abbiamo capito abbiamo scoperto da poco
che produce un alcaloide l'account
decina che viene utilizzata per curare i
tumori quindi un effetto antitumorale
ma la biodiversità dobbiamo mantenerla e
questo l'obiettivo del nuovo orto
botanico
anche perché sorreggerli eco sistemi
influisce molto si clini delle varie
fasce le varie biomi della terra e
quindi la biodiversità è la base ci dà
la vita noi dobbiamo sempre pensare lo
abbiamo visto anche in altri interventi
che la biodiversità è importante proprio
per
permetterci di
affrontare il nostro futuro
l'orto botanico nuovo che vedete in
un'altra prospettiva qui ci darà anche
un impulso innovativo
all'attività di ricerca e di didattica i
docenti si sono spostati negli anni 90
al dipartimento di biologia quindi la
ricerca un po scemata all'interno
dell'orto botanico ora sarà possibile
fare ricerca seria ricerca serie volere
anche didattica seria quindi il giardino
della biodiversità
e possiamo pensato se volete per restare
nel tema di oggi come un ecosistema che
fa da interfaccia con l'ambiente perché
vedete che il nuovo alla nuova struttura
è perfettamente integrata nel
contesto urbano farà da interfaccia con
il visitatore che potrà appunto fare
questo viaggio ideale tra i biomi o
conoscere gli usi costumi dell'uomo e
che ha sempre utilizzato le piante e
farà da interfaccia con la ricerca
scientifica e la didattica che avranno
un beneficio e quindi l'orto botanico
porterà avanti la sua tradizione di
cultura e diffusione della conoscenza
botanica